hello everyone and welcome back to the
very strong Riga introzoneal Tournament
of 1979 we've seen the two-game style
played in in the first two rounds his
second game win with the black pieces
against level polyevsky is a true
vintage style Masterpiece if you haven't
seen it do check it out it will be the
first link in the description below and
I I urge you to check that one out
before watching this uh but this game
also very interesting because here uh
tal sort of faces uh his student or Oleg
romanishin who is a grand master he got
his Grandmaster title In 1976 already uh
well it could be considered considered a
seasoned Grand Master yeah because in
those days when you were I think when
you were around the level of
international Master you were considered
an improver at chess and you were
assigned a Grandmaster to take you on
your journey and really uh you know
achieve something so tal was the one
that that was assigned to Oleg uh and uh
I imagine uh it influenced his play
quite a lot uh but he's uh I mean even
in his is uh some some of the
tournaments that he played he got
brilliant results for example five years
ago when he was still an international
master in the very strong USSR
Championship he got second share place
with Boris Goku Mika Tao and the Rafael
vaganian so uh they have faced each
other before so the that's something
that you you should know before checking
out this game as it probably influenced
Olex play quite a lot so let's check it
out and see what is uh what is up with
this game and if I I was very interested
in this so so I had to check all the
gramination is still alive he's 71 years
old and he's still an active chess
player like uh even last year uh he
played the Reykjavik open and he got he
got a very nice result uh I think in
2021 and 2020 he played even more
tournaments in 2022 I've only found uh
one tournament so uh incredible but yeah
still an active chess player I didn't
find any games from 2023 but you know
the the the year is still young so let's
check it out opens with Ponte E4 we have
Ponte 5 Knight of three Knights the C6
and talgos for the uh rui Lopez with
Bishop to V5 A6 only goes for the
morphe's defense Bishop A4 Knight to F6
and now castles with Bishop D7 uh Rook
to A1 and B5 Bishop to B3 and pawn to D6
so nothing new here we've seen this many
many times C3 castles with H3 and now uh
Bishop to B7 uh usually here you will
see Knight to the A5 or Knights the B8
the brave variation but here we have
Bishop to B7 and now D4 by tal we have
rooked the E8 making room for the bishop
on f8 Knight beat the D2 with Bishop to
f8 and pawn to A3 so just nicely
developing pieces uh putting pawns on
optimal squares H6 with Bishop to C2 and
now Knight to B8 you need to move your
knight in order to push your beep a c
Pawn to attack White Center Pawn to B4
by tall uh guarding that c 5 square and
now Knight beat to D7 again preparing C5
with Bishop to BQ and now Pawn to C5
with B captures on c5d captures on C5
and now top plays D captures on E5 and
there are some games that have reached
this position and you could consider
capturing an E5 it's perfectly fine you
could play the Knight to H7 and then
bring it to G5 or like decides to go for
Knight to H5 and okay we have C4 by tal
he wants to open up his um uh his his
dark Square Bishop Knight to the F for
now with some ideas of uh bringing the
queen enter game if the knight ever
moves you will be able to play Queen G5
threatened Checkmate uh and here top
lead C captures on B5 and it is now as
of move 19 that this position has never
been reached again uh so okay Oleg
recaptures eight characters on B5 and
top plays A4 he wants to trade here uh
trade of the Rooks and then continue his
play on the king side and in the center
with Queen to B6 biolic and now a
adapters on B5 so tall grabs a pawn and
Oleg has a decision to make does he want
to capture back on B5 or does he want to
go Queen G6 and threaten Checkmate so
you could capture like the queen capture
some B5 Tower play Rook to B1 threaten
some discoveries here and after the
queen moves let's say Bishop B3 tal
would position his Bishops uh very
nicely here and the the game continues
it's a fine position for both white
should be a little bit better however
Oleg wanted more from the position he
played the queen to G6 now he threatens
Checkmate on G2 uh sorry uh first he
played Rook 8 to d8 uh defends the
Knight and also aligns The Rook nicely
with the queen tal played Bishop to C3
and only now Queen to G6
uh threatening Checkmate we have
knighted the H4 now going after the
queen and also the Knight defense
Checkmate on G2 and now Queen to G5 and
okay now you're threatening Knight
captures on H3 so tal plays Queen to G4
he just defends and okay uh how do you
how do you continue this uh all the
captors on G4 with h cap plus and G4 and
now he just wins back a material Knight
captures on E5 uh but the toggles Rook
to A7 and now if you assess the position
uh tal tal is up upon he has a past B
Pawn and he has a double G Pawn so it's
not spectacular but he's definitely he's
definitely better here also he has a
beautiful Bishop pair uh Oleg also has a
bishop parallel not as operational and
Tall has a very very active rook and A7
plus that pass Pawn on on B5 uh
shouldn't be uh it should be very
difficult to actually hold this with
black but uh yeah it it should be
possible so here Bishop to see 8 Oleg
moves the bishop goes after the G pawn
and now Bishop to B3 going after the F7
Pawn so he needs to defend Rook to D7
and now Tau plays B6 and here we reach
the first pause the video moment here
Rook the B7 is played of course you
don't want to capture if you capture
then uh the the pawn is already on A7
and while it's possible to play this
let's say Bishop B7 you you defend here
and now Bishop captures on E5 Rook
captures and the game continues but
basically you're gonna move the bishop
put the Rook on B1 attack the bishop
once the bishop moves probably bring the
Rook all the way to B8 and that's a an
easily winning end game for tal so
instead Rook the B7 was played by Oleg
and now uh feel free to pause the video
and try to find the absolute cleanest
way to utilize your advantage while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on solving this
very nice endgame uh trickery and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is best of captures on E5 and it
it all it's all pretty much forced so
you don't really have a a lot of choice
here Rook captures on E5 and now Knight
to C4 you could also kick away the
knight from F or first with G3 but you
don't have to do at night the C4 attacks
the rook and now the problem is if the
root goes all the way back you will play
Knight to F5 and now the Knight is
coming to D6 and
um that's pretty much it so instead Rook
the E7 was played uh but now Knight to
D6 attacking The Rook ended the bishop
so Rook captures an A7 B captures an A7
and The Rook captures an A7 the problem
is uh you have to decide what to give
the bishop here is hanging and also A8
Queen is coming so you have to stop one
of those threats and uh bringing a queen
into the game is a much greater threat
so here Rook captures an A7 and Knight
captures on C8 and now tal is up a full
piece but Ole thought that maybe he
could win it back he played Rook to C7
now top plays Knight to B6 he gets the
Knight out of a Harm's Way and now Rook
to B7 so it seems Oleg will win back the
piece but it only seems that way so feel
free to pause the video for the last
time and win the game for tall while I
give you a couple of seconds there's
only one way to do it have Abbott
foreign
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always finding
the most precise uh maneuver in the end
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Rook the B1 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this the point is now if black captures
the Knight you will play Bishop captures
on F7 with check which usually isn't a
great idea giving two pieces for The
Rook but remember you were up a piece so
now after King cappers and Rook captures
uh you're gonna be of the exchange up
upon and easily winning you have a rook
for a bishop so of course that wasn't
played I mean Rook to B1 was played but
now not real captures on B6 here Olek
tried Pawn to C4 and now comes Knight
captures on C4 Pawn to C4 is a very
tricky idea uh because if tal actually
captures with the bishop then comes
Bishop to C5 and now okay you you're
gonna have to really work for your meal
you're gonna have to play some like Rook
to B5 then Bishop captures on B6 and you
have to play some like Knight to F5 and
um it was still still you you have to
play a game it's a very uncle if you'll
be able to win this so instead tablet
Knight captures on C4 and now it's just
completely winning nice day to check
into F1 Knights the C3 attacking thouser
can be one but I'll just play Rook to B2
and he was in this position and move 38
to that Allegro Mansion resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here once you capture the phone let's
say Knight captures on e4 you're just
gonna offer a rook trade put your pieces
on optimal squares and uh well black
will have to face the reality that he is
down a full piece he's down a knight and
there's no way to compensate for that
uh sure a brilliant Victory by tal
against uh his student all agreement and
uh out of nowhere uh in the first three
rounds uh tal is uh three out of three
uh first round victory was a great one
he even offered a draw in that one but
his opponent declined then like I said
if you haven't seen his second game
around Victory against levolugski first
link in the description below it's I
mean absolute Master Class of how to
properly attack with black uh do check
it out and uh yeah we'll see what
happens in the rest of the tournaments
tal is definitely having one of the best
tournaments of his life uh so yeah once
again I hope you enjoyed it I would like
to thank London system cover halik Madi
uh Marco still Stephen Connell and
ravishing reptiles YouTube for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and I just
remember I remembered ravishing reptiles
asked me uh via email what is up with
the with the fat bird on my on my
channel here uh it's actually a tribute
to one of the former top contributors to
the channel who was involved with a
Square Enix project he was working on uh
on um on a Final Fantasy game Final
Fantasy XV I don't know if you know it
and that's why I thought as a tribute
I'd put a chocobo there and this is a
type of Chocobo a Fat Chocobo one of the
nicest Birds I I like from Final Fantasy
7 I don't know maybe it's they have them
in other final fantasies I know a Fat
Chocobo from Final Fantasy VII uh so
that's why there's a bird there in case
you were wondering uh so yeah thank you
all I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of your day